welcome to the virtuosa The Vessel
that's going to take us down to the
ancient city of Atlantis
after the existence of the Stargate and
Atlantis will revealed to the public the
location of the city has been a closely
guarded Secret
but the First Time Tours are being
planned to visit the ancient city of
myth
the great cityship of Atlantis tour is
coming to you
I'm your guide and I have to tell you I
cannot wait but before we get to the
wonders of Atlantis let's explore the
virtuosa a little bit more
the city ship of Atlantis is not going
to be the only Wonder of this tour the
virtuosa herself is a absolutely
stunning modern cruise ship
where you will find a million things to
do and hours and hours of amazing
entertainment under a big blue sky
food of course aboard the virtuosa is
second to none you will get all kinds of
incredible Cuisine including puddings
that will make your mouth water and
Stakes that will set you alight
the kids especially are gonna love every
bit of mouth water and food you shove in
front of them
we will of course not only be visiting
the city of Atlantis but many of the
islands in the region as well
you'll get to see some of the most
beautiful things you have ever seen off
the port and starboard side
and then go up on Deck get yourselves a
cocktail and enjoy the Sea View and
those incredible sunsets
[Music]
entertainment you saying well yes you
can sit on deck and enjoy the Sun or
jump in some of the pools or
you can go and explore the on-ship water
park because that's what you want isn't
it on a ship surrounded by the ocean
water slides
as promised we're also going to take you
to several of the islands in the region
and look at this beautiful landscape
it's almost alien in nature but don't
worry you'll be firmly here on Earth
even if we are going to the ancient city
of Atlantis
when we get to the city of course there
will be an opportunity to have several
excursions
but on the way we have a few surprises
as well
some of the excursions are a little
hair-raising
[Music]
[Applause]
back up on the ship though there's
always something to do why not enjoy a
great movie or grab a cocktail go up on
deck and enjoy the Tranquility of the
ocean sailing by
finally the day is upon us and we are
about to see the ancient city of
Atlantis
what do you mean the Atlantis is closing
today
[Music]
foreign